a mother is speaking out only to law and
crime about a use of force incident
involving the former minneapolis police
officer
law and crime senior investigative
reporter adam classville is here with
the exclusive interview
thank you for having me brian uh as
this interview came out when we
had learned uh this is a for my
podcast objections we air on tuesday and
when we learned
when this mother reached out to me and
told me her story and we planned to air
on this stage she was just pulled over
with the significance
of the fact that there were what she
called
some haunting parallels when derek
chauvin had a knee
on her 12 year old child's back the
child she said was having trouble
breathing
the what made the mother step forward is
of course
after derek chovin's conviction there
was another federal civil rights case
one of the cases involving george
floyd's murder
but another case involving a 14 year old
so
when she learned another 14 year old was
accused of had that derek chovin was
accused of these actions against a 14
year old
she came forward to us with her story
and brought a new dimension of the case
in that her child has autism and this is
of course
coming in the context of a nationwide
conversation about mental health and
policing
the senate judiciary committee had a
hearing of it just
two days after derek chovin's conviction
talking about police responses to mental
health crises
there is a police report that the mother
shared with us
that shows that derek chovin who wrote
the report
was responding to a mental health crisis
and
this she wanted in coming to us with
this story
to shine a light on this particular
issue about mental health and policing
adam i definitely want to continue to
talk more about this but first let's
take a listen
to what the mother had to say
even though the reason for my call was
serious
and when he was down on my child's back
it was like
i was pleading with him and he the way
he turned and looked at me and said this
is what we're doing and then
i like i said i'm fiery i don't back
down very easily and i felt
afraid for my life and certainly for my
kid's life at that moment
because the way that he was responding
to my words
adam i understand she hasn't spoken to
the minnesota attorney general's office
or federal authorities about this
incident you kind of touched on it a
little bit but tell us a little bit more
as to why she's coming forward now
so part of the reason was when this was
happening as i mentioned this was a
mental health crisis
and involving her child there were one
among
many involving her child who suffered
from autism
has bipolar disorder and other
uh and other diagnoses so
she was dealing with a lot of things and
after the video of george floyd came out
she came across what is known as a blue
card
that police distribute to crime victims
and
it set her on this search she was
trump was more than troubled by what had
happened to george floyd
she learned about what happened to the
14 year old actually through the george
floyd case when that originally came out
and it set her upon the search she
obtained the police report
she requested the body cam video
the minneapolis police department told
her they did not
have the video we're trying to get some
answers as to why that's the case
exactly so thank you adam for that
[Music]
exclusive
[Music]
you